اذا دونالد ترامب امام القضاء مجددا وهذه
المره بشان قضيه الوثائق السريه التي عثر
عليها في منزله العديد من كبار المسؤولين
الجمهوريين انتقدوا ملاحقه ترامب
واعتبروها استهدافا له بينما تم تجاهل
حوادث قد تبدو مشابهه لما حدث مع ترامب
فما الفارق واشنطن بوست حاولت الاجابه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب يواجه سبعا
وثلاثين تهمه بينها سبع تهم تتعلق
بالاحتفاظ دون وجه حق بوثائق سريه وبرفض
تسليمها اضافه للتامر من اجل عرقله
العداله هنا يمكن تمييز امرين ترامب نقل
الوثائق الى فلوريدا بينما كان الانتقاد
الموجه لهلاري كلينتون وزيره الخارجيه
سابقا هو استخدامها لخادم بريد الكتروني
شخصي لاجراء الاعمال الحكوميه اثناء عملها
الحكومي ما ادى الى مشاركه معلومات سريه
على كمبيوتر او سيرفر غير حكوميه في حاله
كلينتن كانت رسائل البريد الالكتروني
تناقش موضوعات سريه نعم الا انها لم تكن
وثائق سريه بالمعنى التقليدي او وثائق
سريه للغايه وهناك فرق وراجع محامها اكثر
من 60 الف بريد الكتروني سلموا نصفها
لمسؤولين حكوميين بينما تم اعتبار النصف
الاخر شخصيا ايضا ظهرت وثائق سريه لدى
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن لكنها تتعلق بفتره
ما بعد مغادره منصبه كنائبا للرئيس وعثر
على وثائق في مكتب تابع له في واشنطن
اضافه لمنزله في ويلمنكتن بولايه دلاوير
محام بايدن اعلن وانهم تعاونوا في كل
خطوات التحقيق وانهم اعادوا جميع المواد
السريه التي عثر عليها في المكتب والمنزل
الامر ذاته ينطبق على نائب ترامب عندما
اجرى مكتب تحقيقات الفيدرالي بحثا في
منزله بولايه انديانا ليجد عددا من
المستندات التي يحتمل ان تكون حساسه او
سريه هناك في اواخر يناير
ايضا تم تسليم جميع المواد الى السلطات
الحكوميه الى ان اغلقت وزاره العدل القضيه
ليعلن بانس بعدها رسميا عن ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه المقبله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات